جيش من الروبوتات يقتحم ويدافع سيناريو
باتا قريبا من الواقع ولا يقتصر على
الافلام فقط فحروب المستقبل قد يقودها
ويقود معاركها رجال اليون وبعد اعلان عن
انضمام روبوتات لصفوف الجيش البريطاني
خلال سبع سنوات تصريح مماثل صدر من الجانب
الامريكي وان كان مداه اطول رئيس هيئه
الاركان الامريكيه المشتركه الجنرال مارك
ميلي توقع ان تشكل روبوتات عماد القوات
المسلحه لدول العالم خلال 15 عاما مقبلا
طبيعه الحرب تتغير في كثير من الاحيان
ولاسباب عده بينها طبعا السلاح الجديد
كالذخائر الدقيقه والدقيقه التوجيه مثلا
لكن التكنولوجيا العاليه وفق الجنرال
الامريكي ستعمل على تغيير طريقه خوض
الحروب كما غيرت قدرات كشف وتشخيص العدو
طريقه الاستهداف الروبوتات مشاهدينا او
الرو الاليه وفقا للتوقعات الغربيه ستدخل
القوات البريه والبحريه والجويه في مختلف
الدول خلال اقل من عقدين حيث تبحث مؤسسات
صناعيه دفاعيه امكانيه استخدام المركبات
القتاليه البريه والسفن بدون طاقم قياده
وتشغيل علما بان معظم الطائرات بدون طيار
والمركبات البريه والبحريه غير ماهوله
تستلزم بعض التدخلات البشريه احيانا كما
هو معلوم
[موسيقى]